good morning John and good morning
nerdfighteria if it seems at all like
for the past few days John and I have
been a little bit weird it's because we
have there are a lot of really amazing
things that make up what we do on the
internet and there's the stuff that we
do that John and I do and I think
objectively what John and I are doing
here if you just count me and John it's
not interesting it's not even like that
good sometimes I make stuff that I'm
proud of but it's never nearly as good
as most of this stuff that that counts
as entertainment in this world and I'm
grateful for everyone who disagrees with
me on that point but I think objectively
what's really actually interesting about
what we're doing here on the Internet is
when it goes beyond just two brothers
and moves into being something that's
very large and encompasses a lot of
people doing a lot of work to make a
community happen and to make it exist in
a very real way one of the primary
people that we feel very connected to
and have been very impressed by and very
sort of moved that he is interested in
this is a guy named Tom you may know him
better as Ning master Tom he is kind of
more or less the de facto leader of our
community at nerdfighters comm tom has
done a lot of things to make
nerdfighteria better if you go to his
youtube channel you could see some of
the things that he's designed he's a
graphic designer he's going to school
right now for graphic design and he's
been a huge part of organizing the
community and making nerdfighters calm
work and really we've been hugely in his
debt for a long time and we have
actually have offered to pay him for his
services several times but he has is
really sincere about the fact that he
wants his services to be about the
community and about his love of what's
going on here not about making money the
reason I'm talking about Tom well
obviously he's not doing this for credit
is because Tom he was riding on his bike
and he got hit by a car and he hit his
head we didn't want to talk about it
until we knew more until we talked to
his family and we've done that now and
they think that he's probably going to
be okay but it's not going to be like oh
he wakes up and he's fine like in the
movies we don't know yet how seriously
he's injured he was unconscious when the
doctors got him to the hospital he's
woken up several times but they've put
him back to sleep because he is not
ready to be awake yet he did recognize
his family
the times that he woke up so that's a
very good sign but John and I are very
nervous about what's going on with Tom
and what I want right now is for the
thing that Tom has spent a ton of time
believing in and and working for which
is our community to just come together
for a bit and like focus on love and on
the belief that Tom can make a full
recovery and be just fine as fast as
possible Tom's family has asked us to
keep you guys updated on this and they
have also said that they would be
interested in hearing from people who
have benefited from Tom's work and who
are Tom's friends and who are
nerdfighters just anyone in general you
could email your thoughts and well
wishes and ecards and whatever you want
to put together for Tom and his family
tuning master Tom and gmail.com his
family has access to that account
they'll be checking it and they'll be
reading those messages to Tom hopefully
soon they'll be reading it to Tom awake
and listening so he will get your
messages we'll keep you updated as we
know more at nerdfighters comm and of
course in videos this obviously drives
home the fact that what we're doing here
is real and that were real people
working really hard to make and do
interesting things and I think Tom more
than anyone believes in that Thank You
nerdfighters thank you John thank you
Tom for being such a supporting part of
this community and for helping us do
things that are actually legitimately
interesting in this world and I'm just
so thankful for all of the moments that
we have and that people choose to spend
those moments working on good and fun
and awesome things the email address
again is Ning Master Tom at gmail.com
send them your thoughts and let's all
just concentrate on having Tom get
better soon see you on Monday